[Music]
so let me welcome all of you to this
ninth session is their third year and
philosophers in the midst of history
this is a quarterly series that we're
doing here at the Frank Lyon Burke
partnering with them and each year we
look at one ancient thinker one medieval
thinker somebody from the early modern
period saw up to about the 1700s 1800
maybe and then a late modern thinker so
we've done a lot of people in the
ancient period we've done Plato and
Aristotle in in previous years and in
this time we're going to look at
somebody who doesn't get a lot of press
unfortunately and who I think actually
deserves a good bit more and that would
be Marcus Tullius Cicero I'll talk about
this a little bit later some people
don't consider him to be original enough
to add to the philosophical canon they
would say you know we should be looking
at the curious or the Stoics or people
like that but I actually think he's a
very important thinker and he said a
great influence and it fits in really
well with the grand theme of this this
talk series which is how philosophers
have been formed by the times that
they're living in and how they ended up
having an influence on those times and
with Cicero I think that's particularly
the case because he is formed in the
time that the Roman Republic is is
really starting to go to hell and he's
going to see the end of the Roman
Republic and the rise of Julius Caesar
which takes place over you know quite a
long time he'll see the assassination he
ends up getting killed by one of Caesars
followers or at least you know followers
of that follower you know Marc Antony
and his men and so there's that entire
sort of political sequence there that's
that's very interesting but Cicero was
also very important for bringing Greek
philosophy into it
setting into a Latin setting and that
would have massive effects on the Middle
Ages early modernity so he's a thinker
that deserves to be looked at and so
he's formed by these these things he's
reacting to these events and he's also
shaping the culture and the politics
himself and ultimately you know dies you
could say playing the game of politics
so what I thought I would do is talk
first a little bit about Cicero himself
just some general remarks then I wanted
to look at and I've given you a hope I
hope to be a helpful tack timeline I
realized the prince is a little small
blinking at it but I wanted to pack
anyone have three pages I want to get it
on two pages I wanted to talk about his
involvement in the Roman Republic and
his connection with these these other
historical figures that we we know about
and talk about and how he fits in there
and then I wanted to talk about his
involvement in intellectual life and you
know in his time and then I wanted to
talk about his continuing influence and
why people are in some respects
rediscovering him today after a period
where he'd been discounted for about two
centuries so what I'll do is with these
I always just you know present and I
talk about the things I've got a few
notes here we'll make a few references
to the timeline but you know feel free
to ask questions at any point or make
comments I'll always get us back on
track I should also mention too that
there is going to be another Cicero
related event here in the Milwaukee area
we've just started a chapter of Sofia
which is the Society of philosophers in
America which is devoted to doing events
like this during public philosophy and
we decided that for our first event in
March we and I'm not sure where it is
yet that hell has to be determined we
would talk about Cicero's book on do
which I'll mention during this talk why
you might be interested in so if that's
something that you're you're keen on you
can talk to me afterwards or if you go
to our website reason io comm you can
see our calendar and I'll be putting it
in there so enough of the plugging what
about this guy
Cicero I'm sure all of you have seen the
bust of Cicero where he's you know got
kind of wispy hair kind of a dour face
that's that's the way he's typically
presented Cicero was in the senatorial
class but he wasn't you know one of the
we often hear about you know the
plebeians versus the patricians there
were other classes in between and Cicero
himself belonged to that he was of a
family of people who were sort of on the
rise in Rome and he got very involved in
in Roman politics he you know he did
sort of the thing that we see our own
politicians do you know if you let's say
you wanted to be a politician here in
Wisconsin what would you do first you
got to pick a party right so pick the
Republicans or the Democrats and now now
what do you do there's a big part of it
as a matter of fact in order to attain
certain ranks you had to have a certain
amount of money and Cicero's first wife
brought a dowry that was just enough for
one of those so it was very convenient
for him so raised money what else do you
do like if you how do you do that that's
that's one way to do it I mean nowadays
we would use social media you know you
see like a great example of this is Paul
Ryan has these people who are gunning
for him and trying to take take you know
that spot and probably the one who's got
the best chance of this iron stash guy
alright because he's got a you know big
public profile and and so you yeah you
do that and Cicero actually did write a
piece on election year and at one point
you know sort of like a dirty tricks
manual because his pitch sort of like
here's the things to look out for with
your opponents because politics is
dirty business but what else do you have
like let's say you wanted it let's say
your goal was to become president one
day
you don't just like start running for
president I know some people do but we
dismiss them usually as coos what do you
have to do how do you like start making
your way up the ranks right so you might
start out with I don't know the PTA
right and then you start making a mark
and people start to get to know you
yeah well library boards are a good
example foundations you know you start
to get to meet people and then pretty
soon somebody's like you know you should
run for State Representative and and so
you run and then you make it and then
you know better than that is being say
senator and then some people go from
being state senator to going to the
legislature at the national level right
the Romans had something like that they
actually called it then a name for the
cursus honorum the path of Honor
and so you would progress through these
different things that you know they've
got kind of funny names and and each of
them he had a particular function that's
what's this road ed that's what a lot of
people did during that time if you
wanted to make your way up you would do
that he was also a lawyer to a lot of
what we have heard his speeches for or
against particular people we have some
letters about about law cases that that
he was in and he some of his legal cases
actually had major implications for Rome
itself so he had all of this stuff going
on he's born outside of Rome actually a
good ways from Rome but you noticed that
in his biography he very quickly winds
up in Rome because Rome was the place to
be and he starts studying you know Greek
the Latin tongue philosophy rhetoric law
literature and he's resigning as was
often the case
not with his own parents but you can
think of it as sort of like a couple
person boarding school you know it was
him and his brother with this guy
Lucas Crassus and around that same time
we see there's there's some other people
being born who are going to be important
Julius Caesar
Marcus Porky's Kadem somebody who would
be kind of an ally of Cicero somebody
who is Cicero certainly admired and you
see him moving his way up in in the
ranks he starts his education and
rhetoric and law under sky bola who is
you know very important jurist and then
he goes to war and he fights under kanae
is Pompey's Strabo when you hear about
Pompey you know Caesar and Pompey the
Pompey were talking about there was the
son of this guy can ask Pompey of Strabo
who's Cicero is on the staff with he's
working under him so all these people
know each other they're all they're all
connected in one way or another and you
see that you know he goes to Rome
becomes a lawyer he gets married it's
kind of a marriage of convenience
his wife brings a large dowry that you
know offers a lot of opportunity he goes
off to Athens and to Rhodes to further
his studies also to evade the chance
that he might get in trouble for one of
the cases that he was prosecuting which
is kind of smart thing to do he only has
two kids daughter his elder daughter is
Talia she's born sometime when it looks
like when he's away he returns to Rome
and he starts working his way up Christ
or is sort of a you know like when we
have comptroller's for cities the person
who's in charge kind of a boring job a
lot of people didn't take it that
seriously in Roman history actually a
lot of them didn't do a very good job
Cicero was very scrupulous you know so
he
and actually Kato are great examples of
this they they take these jobs you know
at their word and do the things that
they're supposed to do that a lot of the
people don't and he's such a good guy at
it that they actually asked him to
prosecute the governor of Sicily who's
been like misappropriating funds and so
Cicero does that then you know you see
that you know he's he's appointed one of
the ideal ace these are these are
another set of people these are
responsible for maintenance of public
buildings and regulation of public
festivals they had broader powers that
had to do with public order I mean what
would we compare that to today it's hard
to it's hard to say exactly I guess some
something in the executive branch you
know and eventually he's appointed to
pray chore which is which is another
higher office and and these people would
be given command you know a garrison or
they might be sent out to other places
they presided over trials it was a more
important position and then if you
notice a little bit further on he's
going to become Council and back in Rome
before the fall of the Republic this is
really the highest well it's not exactly
the highest because there could be
extraordinary cases but it's one of the
highest executive functions that you're
going to find there were two consuls and
they had pretty broad power and they
were only elected for a year so this was
part of the Roman you know Republican
government and his ear is a particularly
tumultuous one there's this Cataline
conspiracy that we'll talk about in just
a moment and you see that you know
there's there's a very important trial
and now we start getting into the sort
of roman history stuff as well and if
you look at the in the second column
where it's got the writings you notice
that almost everything the
or that is you know speeches and those I
just left in the Latin though the treaty
sees the things that we we look at as
philosophical works those I gave you the
English translation of and he didn't
write very many of them at first
he writes these later on you notice
towards the end of his life he's going
to die in 43 he'll actually be executed
he's caught unfortunately trying to flee
and doesn't make it out his son of his
son fortunately does but but Cicero
himself doesn't what else should we say
oh there he did have two marriages and
we know nobody is quite sure exactly
what was going on but towards the end of
his first marriage he complained about
her in some way betraying her betraying
him and there may have been some
political things going on certainly
they're they're different family
connections were already getting a bit
strained because of the political
situation and so he divorces her and he
actually marries a younger woman
gloomily up who is officially his ward
and that doesn't last very long and
interestingly why doesn't it last long
because she is unsympathetic when his
daughter dies he's very close with his
son but I think he you could say that he
was even closer to his daughter Julia
she lived quite a long time she and her
mother actually went into mourning when
Cicero went into exile arguably she was
probably on the same level as Cicero
himself intellectually which would have
been fairly rare at that time so you
know when she dies it's a huge blow to
him and so his wife being unsympathetic
he that he was did not go for that he
divorces her over
and then just sort of continues on his
own and and one of the reasons I'll talk
a little bit more about this when we get
to the philosophy part but one of the
reasons why it does the philosophical
writing he tells us is to ease his grief
over the death of his daughter so it's
really quite a remarkable attachment
that he's forming there you know what we
see often in ancient Greek and Roman
history is women you know having very
subordinate roles and not having much of
a place that doesn't appear to be it
have been the case in Cicero's household
so so Before we jump into like the
meteor history how Rome went downhill or
if your partisan of Cicero and the
Empire how they finally got things
straightened out any any questions or
comments before I throw some more stuff
at you well let me sort of set the stage
then so you notice that the very
beginning of that timeline all right I
began it the year before sister was born
this guy Marius is consul for the first
time and you probably remember Marius
and Sola from world history you know
there are sort of rivals with each other
and they were in Rome and Marius
represented the more popular faction and
and he was also kind of a you know
ambitious some might say vain person
himself certainly was was willing to
play fast and loose with the rules he
gets elected consul over and over again
and he his reign is often quite bloody
Sola is a you really militarily inclined
more conservative politician and
commander who himself can be
extraordinarily bloody minded but who
does seem to have more
of a wish to preserve the the Republic
but but as sort of like you know the
Roman Republic in many respects is like
a vase
that's teetering and and every effort to
try to get it you know to stop teetering
makes a teeter a bit more now imagine
it's not just a vase that can fall off
and crash but it's also very delicate
itself so every place you touch it it
kind of crumbles in a little bit that's
you can say that that's what was going
on from about you know the early 100's
all the way through to the to the 40s in
in Roman history so several generations
of institutions being there but
crumbling not being able to meet the
needs of the Roman political community
and the new situation that they were in
I mean if you think about this time in
history what else is happening with Rome
what do you remember from you know
ancient history or if you're watching
some of these shows that they have on
you know they they have whole series now
you know about Rome what else is going
on yeah why are they fighting
early on what are the war is about
they're about like survival and then
they become about hegemony over Italy
and then they become about survival
again because you know Carthage is going
to destroy them if they don't destroy
Carthage or you know Pyrrhus of Epirus
Great King at that time is is also
fighting Rome and Sicily once they get
some breathing space why are they
fighting all these wars
I mean it's expensive why do all that
crazy stuff
yeah they expand and there's some things
about this this expansion you know when
you start expanding quickly you scare
the hell out of everybody else and then
they're often like well we need to take
these Romans down and so everybody was
is trying to do that at one point or
another and then the Romans would take
them on there were also you know
wandering barbarian tribes that would
come in that had to be dealt with
you know the Gauls were a problem they
attacked Rome a couple times in the past
and then out east you have these vast
empires that are rising that you have to
scrap with so you know this has been
going out and that created a great
strain on Rome in part because it
brought in a lot of money and slaves
made people's fortunes overnight which
led to all sorts of economic
dislocations it also led to having these
these soldiers that you have to start
you know figuring on what you're going
to do with after the campaigns are over
and it led to the rise of people who
sometimes we're quite unscrupulous and
sometimes we're thinking that they were
doing things for the you know the
benefit of the whole and you can see
Marius and and Sola as fitting in there
so what we see happening as this
generation that's going to take plate
take part in the fall of the Roman
Republic is being born our Marius and
Sylla
scrapping with each other and their
followers doing so within the Roman
Empire while Rome is fighting everybody
else and trying to conquer these
different people so there's there's a
social war that takes place and the
social war is happening in the Roman
Empire itself but it's called the social
war because the the you know Sookie
or the Allies these are the people who
the Romans had conquered and given kind
of rights to but they weren't Roman
citizens and they wanted to be Roman
citizens they you know they're like well
why don't we have the same privileges as
the rest of you guys and so they fought
and then there's this these wars with
this King Mithridates who is you know on
the rise in Asia kills Romans there
kills a Tribune that was a big deal that
be sort of like if we had a
congressional delegation visiting I
don't know say Sudan and some some
warlord took over
then killed all those congressmen that's
about how serious it was and so you know
these wars are going on and at the same
time you've got this this fighting
between Marius and sulla both of them
want to be the guy calling the shots and
you notice that that around this time so
this would be when Cicero is is you know
beginning his education Sola becomes
consul he invades Rome and Marius flees
into exile myth right ace invades sulla
says okay I got to leave Marius alone
for the time being I'm going off to
fight in the East so that the Empire so
there's actually still something to
fight over when I come back while he's
doing that Marius comes in and his
forces start killing people all over the
place as a matter of fact that according
to some of the ancient sources at one
point in time Marius would walk down the
street and if people would come up and
they would greet him and they would
greet him with a lot of fear because if
he didn't give a greeting back his
followers would kill them so there's all
this this you know reprisals and faction
going on within Rome and then sulla
comes back and when sulla comes back he
becomes dictator the Romans that had
dictators before a dictator is somebody
who was appointed for a certain amount
of time in an extraordinary crisis to
create you know public order or fight
against the enemies and SOLAS people
also engaged in a lot of bloodletting
and Pompey was one of SOLAS lieutenants
so Pompey II actually was at one point
called the butcher of Sola for for all
the things that we're going on and you
see this this you know sort of fighting
going on Sola eventually is going to
resign the dictatorship and
reestablishes consular government
because he wants the Roman Republic to
continue but like I mentioned you know
with the vase is already halfway
collapsed at this point it's been
crushed by Marius and sulla getting
their grubby hands on it and squeezing
it too tightly and it's still wobbling
back and forth and
side forces are coming in to to
destabilize it even more and you see
these these people you know who have
been raised now coming up through the
ranks starting to assert themselves very
strong personalities let's call it one
of them would be Pompey Pompey was a man
very driven by the desire to celebrate
triumph a triumph was was an honor that
you would get when you fought in a war
you know as the general and and you know
conquered the enemy he he was he didn't
seem to be particularly interested in
having power just for its own sake he
was interested in what went with power
we also see Caesar rising at the same
time but there's other figures you know
on the rise some of whom are you know
make these guys look particularly good
like like Crassus for example who's
going to take part in the what we call
the first tram freight and like you see
here we have all these these things
going on right the Sparta can uprising I
think all of you are familiar with that
you know Spartacus leads a number of
slaves they fought the fought for about
two years before Crassus finally defeats
them and that's what makes Crassus as a
public figure he was the richest man in
Rome he prosecutes this war
that gives him public status and we see
these figures getting more and more
power either through wealth or through
doing things or through a perception
that they're the man who can get the job
done a great example of this that I have
here in the church is there's this Lex
Gambino and this gives Pompey special
powers in any region within 50 miles of
the Mediterranean Sea why so he could
fight pirates because piracy was a big
problem and he wasn't just like you know
going around with ships and fighting the
pirates and fighting them there you'd go
to the pirate Slayers or as we you know
nowadays we call them rogue states right
you'd go to the states that are allowing
piracy and deal with them this makes
Pompeii incredibly powerful and so
you've got all these figures kind of
jockeying for position meanwhile you
have Cato and Cicero probably two of the
you know most publicly minded people on
the rise and then you know what do we
see there's the Cataline conspiracy so I
mentioned that I would talk about this a
little bit more this is essentially what
should we call it an attempt to have a
coup or a revolution against Rome
Cataline organizes a conspiracy that's
centered on doing several things one is
assassinating Cicero who is the consul
at the time
another is bringing in foreign armed
forces and overthrowing the Roman
Republic and it's not exactly clear what
they're to do after that because they
never got that far the conspiracy gets
found out Cicero procures a declaration
of martial law and gives a number of
speeches against Cataline you know sort
of listing what his followers are doing
and denouncing his senatorial
sympathizers because he's got he's got
some people within the Senate backing
him so this is a real live you know
crisis at the time and here's where it
sets certain events in motion it's an
open question what should you do with
traitors these are these are people who
are planning on taking over Rome should
you pardon them should you send them
into exile should you kill them what
should you do this is still a question
we're facing today in our own politics
you know it's debatable about who
exactly is a traitor and who isn't
but once somebody gets accused of
something like that you see you know a
lot of vehement denunciation coming out
so what ends up happening is
the Senate was deliberating on what the
punishment ought to be and Caesar
actually thought that life imprisonment
in various Italian towns would be a good
thing sort of like exile but in Italy
they'd be able to keep tabs on all these
people Cicero and Cato both together
thought that you really have to root out
the poison and so they were for the
death penalty they ended up inflicting
the death penalty without having a trial
and this would come to haunt Cicero
later on because within a few years one
of his political rivals who was at that
time that was called the Tribune for the
plebs you know the Tribune for the
people and act the law and sometimes
laws could be retroactively active we
call it we're not allowed to do this
here in our country thank God but they
would like enact laws and then the law
would have to bear on somebody that did
something before and so you know it was
declared that anybody who had killed a
Roman citizen without a trial had to go
into exile which meant that Cicero then
and you see on the timeline Cicero is
forced into exile because of that so
that's kind of a setback and you know
it's not it's not terrible for Cicero in
certain respects because he gets to go
to Greece and spend time but it was very
depressing for him his house his land is
confiscated has his wife and daughter go
into mourning and he finally gets it
recalled from exile because this guy
titus Annius Milo is consul that year
and and with Pompey's help they bring
him back and then things start to get
worse and worse now we've got all these
different you know things going on right
pretty soon people start to think what's
going to keep order if you have so
imagine that we're in a situation like
that what if we had say ten different
powerful personalities
or twelve or however many and each of
them has a following and we do have some
sort of institutions but they're kind of
using the institutions some of them for
their own gain or to jockey for position
what might be a good solution to that
how might we keep peace well let me ask
you this when we see reality shows what
do they do in reality shows to try to
give themselves an edge or to keep some
sort of peace well that's that's one
thing so you can kill your opponents
right and voting off in this case means
exile or death it's not that you go back
to Indianapolis or whatever you know and
take up your life what's that alliances
yet coalition's and we think of you know
like Roman history in terms of these two
major triumph earrings you know three
men rules but Cicero I actually had the
chance to get in on the ground floor on
the first one Caesar comes to him and
says it doesn't there's no reason it has
to be a three man rule it could be a
four man rule you me
Pompey who's Caesar at this time is a
sort of on the outs with because he had
you know there was a marriage connection
and then that that broke down and
Crassus the richest man in Rome who also
you know remembers crush the Spartan
Revolution we could rule together now
think about how attractive this might be
if you don't do this then in a way by
not giving your support you're you're
lending you know some power to the
forces of chaos and look the last thirty
years has been you know this this
process of you know bloody revolts and
you know worrying about the barbarians
out there and you know factions and
reprisals at home shouldn't shouldn't
you get in on this
wouldn't that be the Statesmen like
thing to do
wouldn't that be the way to serve the
common good this is the sort of thing
and Cicero writes letters to his friends
saying should I do this or shouldn't I
do this he's really weighing it and any
decides no I'm not going to become part
of it
Cato wasn't even invited apparently
because Cato is you know the sort of
stickler who he's gonna do things the
Republican way and that's about it
as a matter of fact when Cato was a kid
they said you know watched him because
you know Sola was in charge and and Cato
said you know why don't you give me a
sword I'll go kill him I've got no
problem with that and then they're like
yeah this kid we got a we got to keep an
eye on him but you know he thought Sola
was was doing things against the
Republic so what ends up happening the
the tranfer it's going to break down and
when it does part of how it breaks down
I'm gonna jump over a lot of Roman
history to do this well say you know
you're all familiar with the crossing
the Rubicon phrase right
Caesar crossing the Rubicon was
essentially a declaration of war a
declaration of war against who though
well Caesar in a way is wrong why why is
it against the Republic yeah the Senate
were the ones who said hey you know
you've been in Gaul you conquered Gaul
thanks for that but you've been ruling
that basically is like the governor
building up military forces doing
god-knows-what over there for years and
years and years what the hell's going on
you need to come over here and give an
accounting you know and Caesars like
well if I do that they're they're
probably not gonna like what I have to
say and they told them to you need to
leave your armies behind just you as a
citizen
need to come in studies like yeah this
sounds like a terrible idea and he
crosses yeah so by this time by the way
Crassus has died so you know think about
a two legged stool guys who don't
completely get along now its Caesar in
Pompeii Pompeii is on the side of the
Senate so what this means is that
neither Pompeii or C's are good guys
they're both basically in it for
themselves neither one is particularly
committed to the Republic but what does
that mean for people who are ardent
supporters of the Republic like Cato or
like Cicero means that they have to
decide what you know what side they're
going to take and at first both of them
are neutral both of them are like you
know sort of like some some people are
like this with with our contemporary
policies like Democrats Republicans or
both dirty you know both equally
involved in taking money from these
people I don't know who I would vote for
you know you're this sort of thing
Cicero and and and Cato we're in a
situation like that but eventually they
decide for Pompey's side because Pompey
is at least supporting the Republic he's
at least not disbanding the Senate or
disregarding their orders and they bet
on the wrong horse
because turns out Caesar is a much
better military commander than anybody
else around and he beats them and and
you know what ends up happening Cato you
know he withdraws to North Africa and
he's really the last of the resistance
there but eventually he commits suicide
when it becomes clear that there's no
way to win and his troops wind up being
executed by Caesar which is a very
strange move on Caesars part because
usually Caesars all about clemency
Caesar does grant clemency to Cicero
but now Cicero is totally out of things
he has no political stake he's you know
he's lucky that he's got anything and
this is when he does a lot of his
writing then what happens
well how long is the Caesar rule as you
know dictator Imperator not long right
there is a conspiracy against him Cicero
was not in on the conspiracy and we know
this because there's a letter where he
says I wish I'd been in on the
conspiracy you know because that you
know that SOB Caesar really had it
coming - he didn't say it in those words
of course that's much said much better
than that but that's that's what ends up
happening and then you know once again
you've got social chaos right and
there's there's a struggle now between
Mark Antony whose Caesars essentially
right-hand man his successor in a
certain way and Octavian who's supposed
to be by Caesars will seize her
successor and they they get into you
know some fighting with each other right
and when it what ends up happening is is
Octavian occupies Rome and and
eventually he comes to terms with Mark
Antony and this guy Lepidus and they
form a third triumvirate now
one of the problems with that is they
come up with a list like I put on here
for prescriptions and prescriptions mean
this is a death list you're you're an
enemy and so they they put senators and
members of the equestrian class on that
Cicero and his son are both on that list
and actually some people try to get him
off of that list and Antony won't budge
and Cicero is apprehended outside of
this place called for Mia he's leaving
trying to get to Greece and he's
beheaded and they bring his head and
some accounts say his right hand some
say both hands back to Rome and nail
them to the walls for public display and
that's that's the end of Cicero and his
political involvement and what happens
after that we know that the the thing
breaks down Octavian becomes the Caesar
Augustus and now we've got an empire so
Cicero is there and he's intimately
involved while the Roman Republic is
falling apart he plays a role in it
plays a losing role but he takes the
good side in many respects Pompey takes
the good side but only because Pompey
you know doesn't want Caesar to win and
he you know it's that that he had a real
long for the Roman Republic Cicero Cato
people like that they were you know real
partisans of that form of government
they thought that it was an important
part of Roman Liberty and this is part
of why he's so influential today before
I go into any of that stuff though any
any questions I've given you a little
long story about what happened with
these crazy Romans and their civil wars
and social wars and you know
prescriptions and a lot of bloodletting
a lot of rivalry you know no well let's
talk then about something more sedate
something more intellectual you know
Cicero he wasn't the only person to
write stuff down or to be a philosopher
Cato was a stoic didn't write as far as
we know but he's actually a character in
Cicero's dialogues Caesar of course
writes a wonderful piece of propaganda
that first year latin students often
have to read the Gallic Wars right
basically he's the kid he's the hero and
the story yeah well he was thinking
ahead so speak a lot of these guys are
very well educated and Cicero is is
particularly so he you know he got to
study with some of the heads or best
representatives of various schools of
philosophy there were there were five
main schools of philosophy in the
ancient world by the time that Cicero's
around one of them is a little bit
defunct and that's that's what I gave
you at the second handout for it
could be useful just to keep track of
all these different things and you
notice that most of them actually come
from Socrates so you have the Platonic
Academy right
Plato probably Socrates most famous
student he starts this Academy he's got
his own philosophy called Platonism you
know of course because plato's thing
just like Aristotelian ism were the
Peripatetic school it's gonna be another
offshoot well then we have these other
interesting schools the Stoics the
skeptical Academy because Plato's
Academy is going to take a skeptical
turn and the Epicureans and each of
these has its own sort of take on what
the good life is what what human beings
are whether we should be politically
involved or not what the cosmos is what
the goal of human life is how we can be
certain or not certain about things what
everything is made of is these schools
they all write long treatises much of
which we've lost except for Plato and
Aristotle stuff unfortunately but we
know from this guide a Genizah Laertes
he's given us lists of titles of books
that we don't have you know so the stoic
school we probably have maybe 10% of
what was written at best mostly from
later authors who have been preserved
Epicurus we have you know he's one of
the most prolific authors in antiquity
we have three letters and two summaries
of doctrine and part of that is because
dad's Laertes actually copied these on
by hand himself if he hadn't done that
we'd have almost nothing Cicero was able
to study this stuff at the source
he read Greek he could interact with the
Greeks he was over there so he comes
back to Rome and part of his mission is
to create will not create to improve
Roman culture so I thought I would
actually read you something from one of
his books this is called the de finibus
or it's usually trance
as on the ends and Cicero begins it he
says it's a dialogue and he's got people
talking back and forth and he says he
says a lot of people say I shouldn't be
writing Latin he says the following
essay attempting as it does to present
Ana Latin dress subjects that
philosophers of consummate ability and
profound learning have already handled
in Greek is sure to encounter criticism
from different quarters some people say
you can't do philosophy in Latin it's
just not a language designed for that
Greek is where it is if you're going to
do philosophy you can't even really talk
about it Latin you just gotta talk Greek
sort of like you see people today who
are a little pretentious and they're
like you know you can't understand John
Paul Sartre in English in English
translation you have to read it in the
French and you know there's a certain
you know say quoi to it you know
basically some things I don't know all
right and or you know people do this
especially with German stuff oh you know
you can't understand Heidegger in
English or or Hegel in English you you
have to read it in the German and when
you talk about it in English you have to
throw in a lot of German words so we
can't you know order Nietzsche we can't
call it the the over man or the Superman
it must be the ubermensch and if we
don't say that we're not really doing
philosophy so there were a lot of people
at that time saying stuff like that
which I just kind of just goes to show
us pretentious people exist everywhere
and at all times right so he goes on and
he says I should make some reply to
these criticisms so he says that here we
go
what astonishes me about those who can't
have a contempt for latin writings is
why should they dislike their native
language for serious and important
subjects when they're quite willing to
read Latin play as translated
word-for-word from the Greek so they're
saying listen you do this in other
genres why why do you think philosophy
so so tricky this way and he goes on and
he says my goal is ultimately to allow
philosophy to speak in
and he did it because area of philosophy
after area philosophy whether it's
metaphysics what we call histology or
you know sort of a study of how we get
to know things what is truth
ethics political philosophy logic all
these sorts of things he doesn't he
pulls it off and the way that he pulls
it off is usually by having a dialogue
and you could say here here's her the
typical Ciceronian thing you know an
epicurean a stoic and Aristotelian walk
into a bar except it's not a bar it's a
library and and they're usually like you
know talking about you know this reminds
me of this thing that happened at this
time Oh tell me tell me about that and
what were their doctrines and then he
goes into it and what's really cool
about it though is that not only does he
have these people present the positions
he has them argue with each other and
say I think that's wrong that doesn't
make sense at all you know you guys you
know see this sort of thing but that's
just nonsense
they make criticisms they they analyze
each other's arguments and in the
process Cicero often doesn't tell you
what side he's actually on and he's good
enough with it that you're getting a
decent epicurean position a decent stoic
position and you can kind of pick and
choose and then a lot of what we know
about what these ancient schools taught
comes to us from Cicero
because of these characters so you know
in his preface 'as I actually went
through it I was looking at the ones
that I have today just to sort of get a
sense of the different things that he
brings up so what we see in the in the
preface is is people engaged in
intellectual debate and discussion
learning from each other he also brings
up another thing over and over again
unsurprisingly which is that there are
troubles within the Commonwealth and he
thinks that philosophy and the other
thing that he was particularly known for
oratory or what we call rhetoric would
come to eight that you know if we
actually studied
philosophy we might be able to overcome
these these problems that were having
and the third thing that he kept on
stressing was that eloquence is a very
great tool and so is reasoning so is
philosophy and we need both of these
because eloquence without the moral
guidance of philosophy turns into you
know mere salesmanship let's call it
right but philosophy without eloquence
pretty helpless can't get much done you
know he actually criticizes the Stoics
who he likes a lot he says you Stoics
the problem with you guys is you think
that you're gonna put the philosophy out
there and everyone's gonna look at and
go oh yeah you're right we should change
what we're doing right you need to use a
little bit of marketing a little bit of
salesmanship and he says I'll show you
how to do that he writes a book called
stoic paradoxes where he's actually
doing that just to show that it could be
done another thing I'll mention too
about what Cicero and and his view so I
mentioned that you know these are
dialogues between different positions
and I did say that we we sometimes can't
tell where Cicero himself stands that's
because Cicero is an eclectic when we
use this determent Kleck t'k I think
most people today are used to thinking
about in terms of music or like
furnishings and what do we mean when we
say like I have an eclectic taste in
music which I'd actually don't I mostly
listen to heavy metal and classical and
a bit of hard rock my wife has very
eclectic tastes those of you who know
her she listens to everything across the
board what does it mean to have a
collective tastes nice yeah very good
so what's that yeah I mean literally
it's you know picking a little bit of
this and a little bit of this that
that's the you know a collecting is
taking in different things and Cicero is
doing that with philosophy he says that
he's a member of the you know the
Academy which was the skeptical school
of the time but for somebody who's
supposed to be a skeptic he sure takes
on a lot of risk
Kilian and a lot of stoic philosophy and
in one book actually says well if it
wasn't an academic I would actually be a
stoic and stuff and so he's really
blending together different strains and
saying well you know I mean why would we
why would we throw out the baby with the
bathwater you know why why would we say
just because I belong to this school I
can't take on things from from other
schools if they've got things right the
other thing that I really like about
Cicero is that he stresses that the life
of philosophy should not be a purely
intellectual life as a matter of fact he
would probably look at most philosophy
professors and say you guys are failing
in your calling he thought that you
needed to be actively engaged in your
community and he actually faulds Plato
himself for giving people a pass for not
being involved in just doing philosophy
he says you know Plato's right they're
usually pretty harmless you know if
you're just studying philosophy at least
you're not like robbing your neighbor or
getting involved in political Tiff's or
stuff like that but you're not actually
doing any active good you're not you're
not resisting evil when it takes place
you're not trying to further justice he
thought this was very important Cicero
himself could have retired and not been
involved in Roman politics but he does
get involved and and I think that's an
expression of how he viewed philosophy
philosophy needs to be something that
really commits a person to what they
call the active life not just the
contemplative life the other thing that
that I'll say that that's quite
remarkable Cicero is what you call a
virtue ethicist and and virtue of this
would be you know Stoics Aristotle Plato
there's you know things like justice or
courage or temperance and and we ought
to possess these traits and we should
try to get away from the vices which are
opposed to them and that's what makes us
good people you know so if we want to
realize what it is to be a human being
we need to try to cultivate wisdom or
try to cultivate
Taurasi or you know whatever the other
virtues are Cicero says that's all true
but we want to be realistic about this
you know the Stoics sometimes an even
Aristotle would set the bar so high it
seemed like nobody could really meet it
that's not helpful for us if we want to
try to figure out how to become better
people and say our relationships and our
job and in our actual lives that we live
we need to look at examples of people
that we know that have these traits and
they're not perfect but they're pretty
good they're better than us we can look
up to them and say you know that guy
still loses his temper but he's a hell
of a lot better off than I am with with
respect to the emotion of anger or that
guy is you know not just all the time
but he's you know a lot better off than
I am and so he says we should we should
do that we should pick examples that we
we can actually relate to not some you
know totally high up there we have no
way of comparing ourself to this this
perfectly wise person who's almost you
know like a semi-divine that's we we
don't have to worry about that sort of
stuff
and when we look down towards others who
are not as far advanced we should
recognize he says whatever outlines
whatever vestiges whatever tendencies of
virtue they have in them and try to
cultivate that instead of saying well
you're not measuring up to this so
everything you do is crap you know we
should say oh wow so most of the time
you're a coward but you're actually
showing a little bit of courage here I'm
gonna encourage that you know and maybe
next time it won't be you know you want
to jump through so many hoops that are
going to do the right thing that's
that's the sort of thing that Cicero
advocated he's not saying give everybody
a pass and you know or as we say give
everybody a Goldstar but he is saying
that we have to be very realistic and
what we expect of people how we measure
ourselves and in the ideals that we we
pick so that's that's a lot
you know of stuff about intellectual
life I should pause for just a moment
any questions or comments that spark any
thoughts anything that we've talked
about before I think you want to go back
to or if not I'll jump right into his
influence which has been pretty
significant less in the last two
centuries then pretty much since he died
and any other point in time even in his
own lifetime he was he was considered a
very important person and you see
Plutarch you know including him in the
parallel lives quintillion a very
important teacher of rhetoric said that
Cicero was not the name of a man but of
eloquence itself so that's you know
pretty high praise right there and a
good turn of phrase for a rhetorician
has a lot of influence on early
Christianity I'll give you just a couple
examples so Augustine said that he was
converted to Christianity in part by
some of Cicero's writings unfortunately
those are lost okay we we don't have
those as a matter of fact some of the
texts that we have are fragmentary
Jerome who was over in Palestine one of
the early church doctors he'd like
Cicero's so much that he actually had a
dream or vision perhaps where he was
being accused of loving Cicero more than
the Gospels and he sort of like somebody
who I don't know maybe they like
watching TV too much or exercising too
much he's like I guess that to back off
on the Cicero because it's just too
wonderful because because I'm supposed
to be focusing on the Gospels so that
tells you you know quite a bit his book
on duties or de ethic is that will
provide a model for a lot of Christian
writings similarly you know Ambrose has
on the offices of people in the church
it's it's essentially sort of
Christianizing
on Duty's there's a lot of things going
on like that and he would have an
influence on you know not just Joaquin
but we Thea's Isidore of Seville very
important sort of encyclopedias al Cohen
who's a person who's taken part of the
Kerala Ginny and Renaissance you know
trying to reconstitute learning in
Europe learning for them in some part
means Cicero and the monks copied
Cicero's texts because they thought this
stuff is worth preserving it's a matter
of fact are you guys familiar with this
notion of the virtuous pagan there's
some things anyone go to Catholic school
and get this drilled into their head so
the virtuous pagans this is how you deal
with the problem that comes up in
Christian theology
you know before Christianity comes
people are kind of screwed they don't
have the gospel how are they going to be
saved you know there's the Jewish people
and they can be taken care of in this
way but what about like Socrates wasn't
he a good guy why does he have to go to
hell well one of the answers for that is
he doesn't have to we'll find another
place for them for these virtuous pagans
right these people who are doing the
right thing there's other ways to get
around this Clement of Alexandria
actually said Greek philosophy functions
like the Old Testament did for the Jews
that works that way for the Greeks it's
a preparation for the gospel there's a
lot of ways to handle this but Cicero
gets counted as one of those virtuous
pagans and probably you know within that
framework it makes sense so that goes on
and they're they're you know continuing
to copy his works what they have of them
sometimes losing them in the process in
in these monastery libraries he also
plays a very important role in sort of
giving the medievals things to think
about in terms of natural law rights
duties that plays an important role his
works are read to study rhetoric so
those are those are continuing
unfortunately they tended to cite from a
non Ciceronian work that had been
attributed to him but you know that
that's that's quite all right that
happened a lot in the Middle Ages that
sort of thing
and Roman and medieval Christian writers
also referenced some of his works in
ways that have passed them down to us in
fragments which is kind of good and then
you know in in the Renaissance
Petrarch discovers these letters of
Cicero and it starts leading to not just
looking for Cicero in monasteries but
looking to see what's in these monastery
basement libraries where all these old
manuscripts are and so Cicero
discovering his his letters and and
saying oh this is cool stuff let's let's
make new copies of this leads to the the
whole classicist movement within the
Renaissance that influences Erasmus that
influences Luther within you know later
centuries Cicero is going to be a big
influence on John Locke on Montesquieu
on David Hume and through that he's
going to influence the people who will
eventually become our founding fathers
and the United States Cicero is widely
read throughout the 18th century and
very why very highly respected as a
matter of fact if you read somebody like
David Hume you would get the idea that
Cicero is probably more important when
it comes down to like you know really
thinking things out and then Aristotle
who the school men were all about or
Plato Cicero is probably more on top of
things now why do things change so I
actually earmarked a portion of this
introduction that not in this one in
this one that gives you a good sense for
why they thought you don't need to study
Cicero anymore this is a guy writing in
a introduction to a Cicero book so
presumably he's got some as they call it
skin in the game right he cares enough
about Cicero to be translating
and here's what with the the wood rack
and the translator says Alexander the
Great died in 323 Aristotle in 322 both
Epicurus and Zeno the founder of
stoicism began to teach in Athens about
20 years later the date marks a new era
and Greek thought as in Greek life
speculative energy had exhausted itself
the schools of Plato and Aristotle
showed little vigor after the death of
their founders enlightenment had
undermined religion yet the philosophers
seemed to agree about nothing except
that things are not what they appear and
the plain man's distrust of their
conclusions was raised in to a system of
skepticism by pyro and it goes on and on
and he ends up saying that you know all
of this is kind of second-rate when it
comes to philosophy
what about Cicero himself well you know
because his work is is interesting but
if there's nothing really original about
it it's it's just kind of taking Greek
ideas and gusting them up in Latin prose
and you know putting them in people's
mouths and so really if it was lost
forever
it wouldn't be a great loss is that you
know like the the greats in philosophy
and that that was a very common
conception I would say in the 19th
century they saw they thought that you
know with the the decline of the Greek
city-state that Greek philosophy itself
had lost its way
and I think they were kind of careless
readers of Greek philosophy and and
Roman philosophy and then that carried
through through the 20th century even in
a lot of you know among classicists and
people who do know ancient philosophy
matter that many of them just dismissed
everything after Plato and Aristotle
when we read the stuff though what we
find is there's a lot of really
fascinating stuff there within the stoic
school within the skeptics the
Epicureans you know eclectic slike
Cicero later plainness like Plutarch
people read Plutarch's biographies
but Plutarch about half of his work is
actually philosophy that he wrote
himself in the plate inist tradition
very interesting stuff all sorts of
other interesting stuff all along the
way and this has been recognized more
and more I would say over the last 50
years and so it's reached a point where
I'd say Cicero is kind of on the rise
the other thing that I think plays a
major role in that is is the revival of
interest not in Maumee academics so much
but among ordinary people in stoicism
because with the Stoics you know i
mentioned we only have about maybe 10%
tops of what they wrote in antiquity a
lot a lot of the rest has been just lost
although we have tantalizing titles you
know wish we could read these books
because because they sound so
interesting
we have Seneca that's the bulk of what
we've got
we have epictetus we have epic teases
teacher mosso Gnaeus Rufus we have
Marcus Aurelius Roman Emperor his
meditations and then if we want to know
more systematically about stoicism this
is the guy that we have to go to Cicero
because the the speeches or the
summaries that he gives of stoicism tell
us a lot about that even though he
wasn't a stoic so there's been a revival
of interest in Cicero because of that
later on next month I will in fact I'll
be going to the Ciceronian Society to
present a paper on Cicero that that you
know the fact that there is a society at
least tells you that there's some
interest out there this is an academic
one more than than a practical one but
there's some interest out there in in
this guy Cicero and I think he's a
fascinating figure you know what we see
here is somebody who's an intellectual
but he really did live the practical
life how many intellectuals can you say
that about where they are involved you
know just literally a heartbeat away
from you know the rule or power of their
country and in his case it wasn't just
his country it was essentially
civilization in the West you know the
Romans are positioning themselves that
way
he knew all these ancient schools he
bequeaths us this this legacy that helps
us understand them how many people can
we can we say that about I mean I don't
want to de fi him he had his bad points
in some cases people faulted him for
getting depressed when he was exiled I'd
probably get depressed if I was exiled
he took my house away you know but on
the whole you know I mean maybe he
should have resisted Caesar earlier
either you know but it's very easy to to
make those sort of second-guessing
things so what we have here is a
fascinating figure hopefully you know
now you've got a better sense of how his
history forms him and what his role then
is in shaping history now I would say
that he probably shaped history more
than history shaped him on the whole
again something we probably can't say
that much about for most intellectuals
you